we're having a crazy weather these days
across the United States and now
scientists are saying that these drastic
changes in the climate may have severely
hurt this year's crop of coca plants yes
coca plants are in trouble a group is
concerned about the coca plant shortage
and they've made this public service
announcement today drastic changes in
climate could impact even the most
resilient crops like the coca plant the
coca plant is a key ingredient in soft
drinks cosmetics cocaine and teeth and
now a concerned group of citizens want
to protect this essential crop look look
look look I work for a highly respected
Wall Street adjacent brokerage firm and
our livelihood depends on the coca plant
for tea all right
some of us drink tea all day and party
with it all night and then sometimes
through the next day and the next night
after that all right so let's fix this
bro all right I'll run a popular off
dress club host spoonie's I'm not Cleon
so Damone's t if i have to grab a
baseball bat and go out there and beat
the piss out of some myself don't think
I would do listen listen listen listen
okay I forgot what I was gonna say but
seriously don't forget to vote
or reports or mere force I will stop at
nothing until we changed the climate
back
hey you wanna party yeah what's uh these
citizens are so determined to reverse
climate change
they formed a think tank to solve the
problem and there's an after-hours think
tank at spoonie's this message brought
to you by the Environmental Defense
Initiative for citizens addicted to tea
[Applause]
you